[Music]
hey what is up guys i'm kid bhd here
pixel 3a so you may have seen this guy
in a whole bunch of commercials and ads
recently they've been going hard with
those campaigns and a lot of those are
sort of hammering home the same two
points
one
399 that's the price starts at 399 bucks
and two this phone has a better camera
than
others fun fact all the ads just say
pixel 3a and
phone x i could have sworn after seeing
a bunch of these some of them said
iphone x you probably thought they said
iphone x but no they all just say phone
x
but google we all know you're talking
about the iphone x and in the fine print
it says image shot on the iphone 10s so
why not just say pixel 3a versus iphone
wouldn't that make the point even more
powerful
anyway so both those two initial things
are true it does start at 399 bucks
that's how much i paid for this one and
it does have an excellent camera one
that's actually better than the iphone
which by itself is kind of amazing at
this price point but of course there's
more to this phone and i've been using
it for about a week so i'll tell you
about it so bringing the phone down in
price as we know is all about sacrifices
and there's been a ton of focus on this
camera naturally and i'll get to that
but there are a bunch of other things
about this phone to consider best way to
analyze it though is still to compare it
to its bigger brother which is the 800
pixel three they're aesthetically very
similar they even feel pretty much the
same now the pixel 3a is all plastic
instead of glass but they've actually
done i think a great job of making it
feel similar to the touch and i could
swear the plastic 3a is lighter when
holding them next to each other but the
scale confirms they're pretty much the
same weight too
this purplish color is also kind of
funny it looks
basically sort of pale lavender from
most angles but if the light hits it
right sometimes it looks more blue
sometimes looks more white it really
just depends on the environment you're
in but you do get that colored power
button which i appreciate and then the
only place you're losing out on build
quality of this cheaper phone is the
lack of wireless charging and no water
resistance and then you actually gain a
headphone jack huh would you like that
these budget phones just keep the
headphone jack around but other than
that it still really feels like a pixel
oh and i've also noticed the fingerprint
reader on the back of the 3a is a little
bit more recessed than the three again
here's the 3a
and then the three pretty sure that's
because the pixel 3 is all glass so you
have the glass fingerprint reader at the
same level but this is a plastic phone
you still need glass on the fingerprint
reader so they sort of indented it and
then the only other main aesthetic
difference is the display which is what
you're looking at most of the time so
you're getting a slightly thicker bezel
on both the top and bottom and the sides
and the pixel 3a has a decidedly
meh display it's a little bigger than
the pixel 3 it's a 5.6 inch 1080p oled
but it doesn't get very bright to the
point where it actually can be kind of
tough to see it outdoors and then even
when you're in normal indoor
environments it looks fine when you're
staring straight at it but the off-axis
color shift is noticeable it starts to
go cool and a little green earlier than
normal so the display quality itself to
me was a downgrade which is a big deal
to me since i'm someone who pixel peeps
and does a lot of photo editing and
things like that on my phone so if you
do that too you'll notice and then the
speaker is a bit cut off too so the
pixel 3 as we know had dual front-facing
stereo speakers one of my favorite
things about it the pixel 3a still has
that top speaker so i'm glad to still
have front-facing audio but then down at
the bottom the chin is super empty and
you have a single downward firing
speaker at the bottom that comes out of
this grille
but what's funny is if you take some
magnet paper to the back you can see the
speaker is all the way over on one side
and this is common on phones like the
iphone where the grille is just another
resonance chamber for audio to come out
turns out the sound doesn't actually
come out both sides it's just for show
on the 3a you can still easily block the
one side that audio comes out the bottom
grille but again at least it's still
just half of the speaker pair you still
get audio coming out the top so you're
not totally blocking it and the speakers
get pretty loud and they sound fine so
the main concern many people have had
and rightfully so with the pixel 3a is
just
is it slow a lot of budget phones
nowadays or mid-range phones are still
bringing the top high-end specs before
they sacrifice with other things pixel
3a does not have top high-end specs it
has a snapdragon 670 the adreno 615 four
gigs of ram and so if pixel 3 was
already having performance issues what's
this phone gonna be like well i'm here
to tell you after using this phone for a
little while
it performs kind of just like the pixel
3 meaning
it's fine it gets the job done you will
notice it's not as smooth as the higher
end ones and it definitely struggles
with ram management still there are apps
closing in the background only four gigs
of ram but it just kind of works fine i
don't know if maybe i'm even more
critical because i just came from the
oneplus 7 pro which is the smoothest
fastest phone i've ever used but pixel
3a just kind of feels like it chugs
along doesn't care too much about
smoothness and just eventually does what
you say so opening and closing apps and
multitasking and opening files and
editing photos all that stuff it doesn't
lag at all it's just not as fast
but it's not too slow or unusable it's
just fine so this phone also has slower
internal storage than other flagships
and i can tell in the speed of opening a
lot of bigger apps and bigger files but
you know it's not killing me and then
one part of the performance of this
phone that i can say actually does much
better than its older brother is the
battery life because you're only pushing
a 1080p display and lower power
internals and this phone has killed it
with the battery life i've consistently
got over five hours of screen on time
with the 3a usually more and on heavy
days i could just barely kill it in a
day so this is refreshing because some
phones in this budget class do cut down
on the batteries some don't but this one
actually has physically larger batteries
than the flagship brothers so that was
kind of nice to see battery life good on
the 3a so that just leaves the last part
the part that google knows they have on
lock the cameras on the pixel so the 3a
has the exact same hardware for the
single rear camera same sensor same
glass same ois and everything on the
front though you go from dual
front-facing cameras one ultra wide and
one standard to a single selfie camera
that's sort of in between so it's a
little wider than normal but it's not
quite the full ultra wide so it's a good
compromise but in this rear camera this
is the reason to get hyped over this
phone of course photos from the 3a are
very detailed
and have tons of dynamic range and great
color taking pictures with it it's so
easy to forget it's a 400 phone because
no other budget phone takes photos
anywhere near this good especially in
the more challenging lighting scenarios
so like shooting directly into the sun
or in darker lighting things like that
it's no question night sight is still on
another level now something else to note
the pixel 3a does not have the dedicated
image processing chip or pixel visual
core that the flagship has so what does
that mean basically that now it's
processing images on the snapdragon 670
instead i've found that this has almost
zero effect on the actual final image
quality really the only thing you'll
notice for sure is photos take a little
longer to actually process after you
snap the photo that's about it so
overall if pixel 3's image is an a plus
then this is an a and that's still miles
ahead of any other camera of any phone
in this price range so should you buy
a pixel 3a
of course this is going to be a really
good phone at the price for a lot of
people but it's not just as simple as
saying oh it's just like the pixel but
cheaper it's just a little more nuanced
than that there are a lot of other
competitive phones out around at this
price now more than ever before you have
that zenfone 6 that just came out at 500
bucks but that's pretty nice you have
the oneplus 6t and the oneplus 7 out
there the galaxy s9 coming down in price
from last year so there's a lot
happening the pixel 3a chops down in a
couple places where some other mid-range
phones wouldn't have so it doesn't have
the super high-end specs and it's just
never gonna feel
blazing fast and of course no wireless
charging and no water resistance we know
that but it does bring down a lot of
those things from higher end phones like
its big brother that we love so much
like that same fingerprint reader on the
back the same squeeze for assisting is
still there the same really good haptic
motor which is underrated for stuff like
typing and notifications the same super
smart software experience that will be
updated first in line and an even better
battery life and then of course the best
camera quality of any phone so there are
other things that are more important to
some people than just the camera in
which case there's a whole world of
other phones in this world that you can
look into like i mentioned but if you're
in it for the best possible photo
quality and the absolute best software
experience for 400 bucks
you're looking at it right here pixel 3a
simple as that
so there you have it thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one
peace